Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous présente
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans l'émission
littéraire de Public Sénat au bonheur
des livres ce soir nous allons parler
des princes qui nous gouvernent de leur
fonction et de leur personne et nous
avons intitulé cette émission voyage au
cœur du pouvoir pour nous guider dans ce
voyage de notonniers remarquable
Catherine n'est tout d'abord bonsoir
Catherine lorsque vous étiez à Europe 1
vos jeunes consœurs vous avez surnommé
Quinn Catherine pour en hommage à votre
connaissance votre expérience votre
compétence votre autorité en matière
politique mais pour vous décrire le
mieux c'est de s'en remettre à ce
qu'écrit franzelier Giesbert piquante
cultivé et indépendante d'esprit
Catherine Nay est la meilleure
incarnation de cette génération de
jeunes femmes journalistes que Françoise
Giroud la directrice de l'Express a
lancé à l'assaut de la politique j'ai
remercier Franz pour cet hommage qui m'a
touché évidemment et vous publiez chez
bouquin
le Grand Théâtre du pouvoir qui réunit
les quatre best-sellers que vous avez
publié au cours des 40 dernières années
le premier sur le couple Giscard Chirac
le second sur François Mitterrand le
troisième sur la bataille entre Edouard
Balladur et Jacques Chirac et le dernier
sur l'ascension de Nicolas Sarkozy nous
allons revenir à vous notre deuxième
guide c'est Franz Olivier Gisbert Franz
bonsoir bonsoir vous avez dirigé le
Nouvel Obs Le Figaro le point vous avez
au magazine aussi vous avez animé des
émissions de télévision vous avez publié
20 romans dont certains ont eu des prix
prestigieux comme le grand prix de
l'Académie française vous avez publié
autant d'essais et de biographie
politique et là vous venez avec une
histoire intime de la Cinquième
République chez Gallimard la belle
époque qui couvre à peu près la décennie
70 disons de l'accession au pouvoir de
Georges Pompidou jusqu'à l'entrée à
l'Élysée de François Mitterrand et comme
vous connaissez infiniment bien cet
univers comme vous êtes original comme
vous êtes libre d'esprit et talentueux
de plumes je dois dire que c'est très
amusant à lire si vous voulez on va si
vous voulez vous voulez bien on va
parcourir ces années tous les trois et
on va commencer avec Georges Pompidou
pour lequel vous avez France
manifestement beaucoup d'affection et
franchement vu de loin on se demande
pourquoi parce que son bilan comme
président n'est pas fantastique et le
personnage n'est pas très sympathique il
a été planqué pendant la guerre alors
qu'il avait à la fois l'intelligence et
l'âge pour être engagé il a eu des
complaisances
il a eu des complaisances avec les
anciens collabo après on se souvient
d'image à Grenoble où il laisse conspuer
Pierre Mendès France il aime les livres
il aime les arbres mais enfin quel est
le mode qu'est-ce qui fait que vous
l'admirez tant il est très cultivé ça
c'est vrai que c'est assez rare il y en
a assez peu évidemment après il y aura
Mitterrand mais il est très cultivé non
moi ce que je trouve extraordinaire dans
son parcours c'est vrai qu'il a raté sa
présidence ça c'est autre chose et il a
pas été Président il est arrivé malade
c'est ce que je raconte dans le livre
c'est jamais écrit mais en 1969 quand il
était lui président il a déjà sa maladie
et les graves elle est mortelle quand
elle commençait quand elle part cette
maladie devrait être c'est c'est la
personne est condamnée donc il a déjà ça
et puis ça bon cette maladie va la
ronger pendant pendant son cours c'est
un quinquennat il n'a pas fait accepter
là bon ça c'est c'est un premier point
et surtout ce que ce que ce qui est
extraordinaire avec lui c'est ce tandem
magnifique qui le fait avec de Gaulle
c'est-à-dire c'est ça qui extraordinaire
quand il était premier ministre de
Gaulle s'occuper de la France lui
s'occupait des Français il y avait une
répartition des tâches alors c'est vrai
que ça commence à foirer à partir de 67
parce qu'on dit toujours 68 c'est pas
vrai moi je raconte dans le bouquin
c'est poker qui te dit il faut car comme
il adore Pompidou c'est pas il a pas
inventé c'est à dire un moment donné de
Goldie ce type n'a pas de couilles elle
est je vais virer j'en peux plus j'en
peux plus de Pompidou en 67 c'est à dire
un an avant la rupture de 68 et
qu'est-ce qui vous plaît en lui en
dehors la culture la présence vous savez
c'est important Catherine sera d'accord
avec moi je pense qu'elle était là
d'ailleurs ce jour-là quelqu'un m'a
présenté alors je sais pas si c'est
Catherine n'est ou Michel cotta et je me
souviens que c'était une femme m'a
présenté à George Pompidou dans une
espèce de truc de pince fesse à l'Elysée
et si c'est toujours important de
rencontrer les gens vous savez il y a la
nouvelle comment dire la nouvelle
idéologie journalistique c'est dire faut
pas voir les gens ça vous influence bon
bah quand on voit Pompidou on voit
d'abord qu'il est grand 1m82 qu'il a une
espèce oui bien sûr un mètre 82 tu
vérifies 1m82 et qu'il a une espèce de
prestance comment dire une aisance est
toujours un petit sourire aux lèvres
enfin il a une forme de charisme et puis
je dirais la culture et puis et puis une
sort de oui de volonté de se dépasser de
dépassement de la France etc alors c'est
vrai que il a pas donné sa mesure quand
il était président mais ça c'est
absolument évident je me souviens
Catherine que vous aviez dit je ne sais
plus où que la première fois que vous
l'aviez vu
Georges Pompidou vous aviez été
impressionné par son autorité naturelle
que vous n'aviez jamais rencontré depuis
lors
il avait voyez ce nez Bourbonnien et ses
yeux enfoncés dans leur orbite sous des
gros sourcils c'était un regard qui
était à la fois caressant et cruel moi
je n'ai jamais vu un premier ministre
arrivé dans les couloirs des quatre
colonnes avec les députés qui
remplissaient de 10 cm tellement
l'autorité était là c'était le fluide de
l'autorité d'en parler le général de
Gaulle mais on a oublié que ça a été un
grand politique parce qu'il a rejoint le
général de Gaulle des quand il était à
la Libération il était à son cabinet
s'est fait remarquer de lui parce qu'il
savait écrire des notes claires et
l'avantage qu'il avait sur ceux qui
n'avaient pas fait ce qui était à
Londres c'est que lui il avait connu la
France il savait pas été les mots de la
France ce qui manquait combien les
Français avaient souffert de la guerre
ce qu'il fallait faire et donc il a
travaillé auprès du Général de Gaulle
bon il a vu il n'a jamais cru que de
Gaulle viendront pouvoir après l'échec
du RPF donc il est parti il est parti
chez Rothschild avec quand même un
engagement si de Gaulle revenait et
quand de Gaulle est revenu appelé par
les gens de la 4e il a été la cheville
ouvrière c'est lui qui a fait le
programme du général de Gaulle pendant
que le général de Gaulle parlait de
l'Afrique des Jeudis il était ailleurs
il était déjà en politique étrangère et
donc même de Breaking l'aimait pas a dit
qu'il a été le maître du pouvoir et
c'est là que et tout d'un coup il a
découvert que la politique s'était
formidable et après il est revenu chez
Rothschild il n'en pouvait plus et en
fait l'intéressait plus donc moi je
pense que c'est vrai Franz a raison de
dire que il a été un mauvais président
parce qu'il était déjà malade en 68 il
avait il y avait déjà eu moi il était
revenu de vacances il était un peu
bouffi il avait pris de la cortisone et
tout ça il avait fait des analyses de
sang en Bretagne à Carnac et
le maire de Carnac m'avait dit le
pharmacien m'a dit il a très mauvaise
analyse mais on lui a racheté sa santé
vous savez qu'il est toujours bronzé un
peu rond voilà et puis cette espèce de
force qui allait bon mais moi je dirais
qu'il a été un grand président quand il
était premier ministre parce que voilà
parce que je suspecte je suspecte un peu
vous Catherine beaucoup France d'aimer
en lui le personnage conservateur par ce
que je sens en vous lisant que vous
n'aimez pas vous vous n'aimez pas
Chaban-Delmas non non c'est pas vrai
non non non vous aimez vous n'aimez pas
vous n'aimez pas Mendès ah ça c'est vrai
vous trouvez que la nouvelle société de
Chaban-Delmas fabriqué par de l'or et si
mon aura c'est du pipeau vous n'aimez
pas Michel vous n'aimez pas Michel
non non c'est pas vous les aimez vous
les appréciez mais vous considérez que
c'est pas eux qui que vous avez de
l'admiration pour les politiques et vous
considérez que vous ne savent pas
exercer le pouvoir il était trop sympa
il était trop sincère il était trop vrai
c'est ça le problème mais c'est ce que
je dis il était trop bien si vous voulez
d'une certaine manière il nous manquait
pas enfin il y a quelque chose vous
aimez les politiques qui montrent c'est
pas que j'aime c'est que je dis tout le
temps moi j'ai jamais vu rencard comme
un concurrent véritable de Mitterrand et
pourtant c'est dommage parce que d'une
certaine manière
toujours à la fois on l'attendait il y a
eu combien de quand combien de congrès
socialistes ou on l'attendait et puis il
était candidat et puis il dit mais si
vous êtes candidat je m'effacerai enfin
moi j'ai tout de suite vu qu'il n'était
pas comme vous des hommes plongés dans
la gauche j'ai vu que ça tenait pas le
choc il avait pas d'incarnation
présidentielle c'était un homme d'idée
voilà il était très talentueux il était
très compétent un problème de caractère
et on comprenait pas toujours ce qu'il
disait quand même franchement et voilà
mais mais même je vois et on va on va
vous interroger je vous interroger
l'année l'autre mais même je vois que
sur Giscard vous admirez l'intelligence
de Giscard mais vous le trouvez hors sol
or il a été alors vous vous rendez vous
vous rendez hommage sur son bilan
économique mais il a été et même
sociétal aussi attendez il a fait un
nombre de réforme incroyable très vite
et c'est ça mais il a changé la France
d'une certaine manière mais simplement
ceux qui ne va pas avec ce n'est pas
pour lui il affection que vous avez pour
Pompidou par exemple
ah bah c'est parce que Pompidou que j'ai
pas connu j'ai juste j'ai juste croisé
j'ai eu serrer la main quoi c'est tout
c'est vrai que alors que Giscard je l'ai
très très bien connu mais le problème de
Giscard c'est que il a été on peut dire
un grand président et peut-être le comme
disait Max Gallo qui est pourtant pas
suspect giscardisme
Maghreb disait que c'était plus grand
président à padogo on sait dire que
parce que il a fait vraiment énormément
de réforme ils ont fait un travail de
dingue parce que excusez-moi le ce qu'on
a vécu le covid ou la guerre en Ukraine
c'est la roupie de s'enchaînée à côté
des deux chocs pétroliers de 73 de 79
mais c'est la fin du monde c'est énorme
bon il a su faire face donc c'était
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a fait
des choses mais ce qui n'allait pas
voilà soit intégré à la société et lui
donner l'exemple c'est ce qu'il voulait
c'était très bien mais ça a pas été
compris parce que on l'a oublié on a dit
quand même la le regroupement familial
c'est signé par Chirac parce qu'il était
premier ministre mais je veux dire c'est
Giscard qui l'a voulu aussi voilà et
donc
il y a de grands développements de
France là dessus c'est le Conseil d'État
non non il a essayé de dégommer à un
moment donné et le conseil je vous
arrête mais je vous arrête une seconde
après quand barre est arrivé et qu'il a
vu que leur donner le regroupement
familial au moment où le chômage
augmenté il a voulu l'arrêter et donc il
a voulu et le Conseil d'État a bloqué et
donc on pouvait plus et ça a été lancé
et Giscard a dit après oui il la
regretté mais je veux dire il y avait un
parfait consensus entre Chirac et allait
partir trois mois après vous pensez bien
que s'il était pas d'accord il l'aurait
il l'aurait pas fait c'est Giscard qui
voulait mais quand on regarde le bilan
notamment de la première partie du
septennat de Giscard en terme de
libéralisation de la société française
c'est un bilan incroyable il a fait ce
que la gauche aurait rêvé de faire au
fond oui de des libertés de de de
divorce de la
de la majorité oui tout ça oui c'était
vrai le personnage était étrange mais le
bilan est quand même assez ça a été un
grand réformateur qui n'était pas
compris et surtout politiquement qui n'a
pas compris que il fallait plutôt que de
vouloir lancer ponial à l'assaut du Eder
qui était la majorité de sa majorité qui
a compliqué les choses parce qu'il
disait qu'il voulait les tuer s'il leur
avait fait les yeux doux s'il avait su
les mettre dans sa poche sont sûrement
que son septennat aurait été plus apaisé
alors le grand antichement de de France
comme vous le dites vous-même c'est
Mitterrand c'est François Mitterrand
vous faites d'ailleurs de lui un
portrait d'une incroyable humanité de le
personnage est extrêmement sympathique
son rapport avec le temps dont on a
beaucoup parlé
sont le grand amoureux qu'il est même
son rapport avec vous parce que oui il
est il est votre mentor enfin il vous
prend en affection dans ce qui faisait
avec plein de gens je suis pas le bien
sûr c'est une mentalité de Pygmalion
c'est à dire que il essaie toujours vous
apprendre la vie dès que vous aviez
moins de 30 ans quoi mais vous mais vous
passez rapidement enfin il est quand
même un certain égards d'un grand
cynisme en politique je trouve ça pas
l'air de vous gêner de plus que ça bon
vous avez la suite vous avez le
troisième tome je suis en train d'écrire
parce que sur l'économie dès qu'il
arrive au pouvoir c'est quand même autre
chose c'est un grand cynique vous avez
raison ce rapport par exemple avec le
Front national de Le Pen enfin tout ça
et puis sur le plan économique des
erreurs absolument monstrueuses mais
attendez là on est dans la période de
prise de pouvoir et c'est la période où
je le suis je suis jeune journaliste et
je le raconte tel qu'il était et
peut-être effectivement
j'avais un accès plus facile jamais
compris pourquoi parce que peut-être il
se disait qu'il allait modeler il
voulait que je fasse de la politique etc
donc je l'ai effectivement il m'a fait
des tas de confidences mais je pense
qu'il était plus facile à connaître que
par exemple Chirac c'était quand on
avait brisé la glace avec lui il parlait
quand même moi je me souviens de
conversation avec lui ils disent des
choses que pratiquement aucun homme
politique ne m'aurait dit c'est à dire
il y avait une
il était pas si secret que ça ce qui est
vrai vous avez employé le mot
abominablement civique mais ça c'est sûr
prêt à tout enfin de Gaulle est un autre
dans le genre aussi on regarde mais au
fond vous avez plus d'affection pour ces
pour ces hommes politiques qui ont la
science de la politique de la manœuvre
qui sont cyniques qui sont capables de
passer des alliances contre nature si
c'est le moyen d'accéder au pouvoir que
pour ceux qui sont dont vous pensez que
ce sont des naïfs même si leurs projets
parce que donc si vous dites ça pardon
monsieur Chaban Chaban j'ai voté Chaban
premier tour en 1974 d'ailleurs j'avais
dit à Mitterrand qui m'avait dit vous le
racontez
on ne pouvait pas ne pas aimer Shaban
vous savez pourquoi il passait pour un
con parce qu'il était gentil c'est ça la
vraie histoire de Chaban il était très
compétent il était très courageux il
faisait des tas de trucs il faisait un
peu trop de choses c'est-à-dire c'était
l'époque où voilà un politique il était
président de tout etc il allait d'un
truc à l'autre mais il allait vite et et
moi c'est quelqu'un que vraiment
j'apprécie énormément et rocker c'est à
peu près la même chose aussi c'est à
dire que je pense que la politique ça
n'est pas forcément du cynisme bon le
problème de requin c'est que
effectivement face
Mitterrand il avait pas beaucoup de
caractère quoi Mitterrand il savait ce
qu'il voulait Catherine vous avez écrit
un livre sur Mitterrand qui
vous avez écrit un livre sur chacun son
tour vous avez écrit un livre sur
Mitterrand qui a été un best-seller à
l'époque mais qui voulait qu'il a
moyennement émet enfin il vous a vous
avez fait un portrait contrasté de lui
psychologique et il a plus ou moins aimé
ce portrait égal qu'il moi je ne voulais
pas le voir
je voulais l'appréhender en vrai en
faisant parler tous les gens qui
l'avaient connu mais bon moi mon
Mitterrand j'ai jamais eu vous savez
d'abord par fonction à L'Express c'était
Michel qui s'occupait Michel cotta qui
s'occupait de la gauche et moi de la
droite donc moi j'avais pas mes entrées
aux parties socialiste et Mitterrand moi
il me glacé je croyais qu'il avait un
regard en biais ce sourire un peu
arrogant et puis il y avait quand même
on a oublié qu'à l'époque comme la
gauche a toujours été le camp du bien
mais les journalistes qui étaient
droites étaient très très mal vu en
entrait pas comme ça quand on était
journaliste dit de droite parce que je
m'occupais de la droite dans le camp
socialiste donc moi j'étais mal à l'aise
avec ces avec les socialistes et puis
quand les premiers les premiers congrès
socialistes où j'ai vu Mitterrand arrivé
mais la Cour les courtisans la façon
dont cet homme là a été et c'est vrai
que il a profité son ascension politique
parce que il s'est remis de quand même
de l'affaire de l'Observatoire parce que
c'était un moment il y avait pas
Internet et que comme il disait les
Français sont un peuple sans mémoire
mais il a profité de quoi de la
médiocrité du personnel socialiste mais
son parcours c'est celui d'un artiste de
la politique quand même se poser face à
de Gaulle le mettre en ballotage et
après être bien voilà je suis la gauche
à moi tout seul alors il a mis 23 ans
avant d'y arriver bon mais moi je veux
dire c'était un homme que je n'aimais
pas du tout je l'aimais pas du tout mais
je ne sais ce que vous étiez
son intelligence par sa culture et par
sa capacité de d'État parce que
finalement rétrospectivement quand on
regarde ces deux c'est deux septains
non le second je suis pas impressionné
mais là il a fait les grandes réformes
je veux dire la retraite à 60 ans qui
était la réforme par contre à contre-ci
que en Espagne puisqu'on gagner 3 mois
par an même des grands économistes de
gauche disent qu'il aurait jamais fait à
lui faire ça je vais dire et puis il a
fait quand même le programme de la
gauche avec deux plans de rigueur enfin
je veux dire alors il a une sensibilité
c'est vrai de générosité sociale parce
que un milieu catholique de voilà ou moi
je crois je crois que dans ça en enfance
il a connu la lutte des castes avant la
lutte des classes où il y avait vous
voyez les mitterrans faisaient du
vinaigre tandis que le haut du panier il
faisait du cognac vous voyez c'était la
différence et on se mariait pas entre
ces gens là on voit aussi énormément le
portrait de France et dans le vôtre
puisque là on essaie de parler de leur
personnalité une sensibilité de
proximité en tous les cas avec les gens
qui sont autour de lui un souci de
prendre soin à contraster
une forme de une forme d'infini une
forme de fidélité dans l'amitié
bien sûr qu'il avait des qualités
formidables il faut voir aussi que
comment sa vie privée quand même se dire
c'était le
il a eu c'était vraiment l'homme qui a
pu le dernier qui a pu jouir de cette
liberté de mener des vies sentimentale
et pluriel et qu'on ne disait rien
c'était le secret absolu donc il a il a
joui du pouvoir comme aucun homme aucun
président vous voyez comme partir en
hélicoptère le samedi jouer au golf à
l'autre bout de la France et tout ça
mais il en a à prendre l'avion pour
amener Mazarine à Venise pendant les
vacances de Pâques mais plus aucun
président n'ose refaire ça il a été un
moment où tout était tout lui était
permis parce que il y avait pas la
presse people il y avait pas les il y
avait pas Internet il y avait pas tout
ce qui aujourd'hui fait que c'est les
censeurs sont partout et que les hommes
politiques et que d'ailleurs la
politique n'intéresse plus personne vous
voyez bon on pourrait continuer à
défiler cette république on pourrait
parler de Chirac que vous avez beaucoup
aimé et l'un et l'autre et c'est presque
le personnage qui vous paraît Alain et
l'autre le plus sympathique peut-être
parce qu'il le moins mégalo Catherine
n'est pas mégalo mais il ne s'aimait pas
et quand il pouvait dire du mal de lui
je suis mauvais comme un cochon et tout
ça qu'est-ce qu'il en pense je ne sais
pas je suis con voilà mais moi je lui
disais mais allez vous dire vous savez
moi j'ouvre la bouche et j'attends que
ça sort donc c'est quelqu'un ça c'est
vrai qui est absolument insaisissable
mais toujours dans l'empathie donc en
surface on avait l'impression qu'il se
livrait qu'il se donnait alors que dans
le fond il ne se donnait qu'à lui-même
quoi c'est un personnage comme ça je
pense qu'il n'a eu aucune jouissance du
pouvoir ce qui l'aimait c'était la
conquête voilà et après ça l'ennuyait
franchement il est recevoir les
ministres tout ça c'était
c'est je sais pas quelle idée il avait
de la France dans le fond lui il pensait
que depuis Mai 68 que lorsqu'il y a un
problème et bien on ouvre les vannes on
fait un Grenelle et voilà donc il
faisait des Grenelles tout le temps
donner aux gens ce qui n'était pas
forcément une éducation du peuple qu'il
fallait c'était gâté les enfants voilà
mais on l'a aimé parce que on a des
souvenirs de bons moments avec lui et de
et de profond de gentillesse voilà je
dirais pas qu'il a été un grand
président je renvoie à ceux qui nous
écoutent et nous suivent à la lecture de
vos deux ouvrages parce que c'est une
galerie de portrait un voyage
fantastique à l'intérieur de ces
dernières années petite question pour
vous France vous êtes en vous lisant je
vous trouve incroyablement réac vous
avez une vision de la France une espèce
de carte postale sépia d'une France
rurale plutôt de couleur blanche mais
elle est imaginaire si elle est purement
nostalgique elle a jamais existé
la France c'est c'est et puis il y a
toute une histoire il y a enfin moi je
sais pas je me sens très français
peut-être très patriote c'est un mot qui
vaut plus prononcer aujourd'hui et
j'adore ce pays et c'est peut-être ça
que ça peut gérer certains je le conçois
très bien aujourd'hui parce que le grand
truc c'est dire que c'est un pays
affreux
colonisateur raciste tout ce que vous
voulez mais c'est vrai j'aime ce pays et
je suis désolé mais je crois que je vais
continuer à l'aimer beaucoup beaucoup
encore
l'aimait forcément comme une image du
passé moi face à un autre débat on va on
va poursuivre on va poursuivre si vous
lever notre conversation avec un lecteur
qui va poser une question je crois que
c'est à fond de l'olivier qui l'a qui
l'a pose et ce lecteur c'est Noé
[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Noé je suis
étudiant en Master 1 journaliste et pour
moi lire c'est vraiment synonyme
d'indépendance c'est acquérir tous les
savoirs et les connaissances pour
pouvoir affronter les opinions ou les
influences de mon entourage que ça soit
dans le milieu politique ou pour les
questions sociales voilà donc pour moi
le dire c'est l'indépendance
mon gros coup de coeur dernièrement on
livre c'est le journal de Kurt Cobain
donc ils ont retranscrit tout le journal
intime de la grande route Rockstar et le
chanteur de Nirvana mais pour moi
au-delà d'être un journal intime de
grandes Rockstar planétaire ceci le
jardin intime d'un jeune qui essaye de
décrypter une société qui ne comprend
plus et pour moi ça c'est très important
surtout aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de
problématiques
dans lequel les jeunes se sentent
concernés si j'avais une question pour
vous ça serait en quelle personnalité
pleine d'espoir pensez-vous que les
jeunes de 20 ans aujourd'hui
puissent croire pour le futur difficile
qui se dessine à l'avenir
France ce qui est un personnage que vous
dites qui peut porter les espérances de
cette jeunesse comme certains des
personnages que vous avez décrit l'un et
l'autre les ont porté autrefois
franchement je suis sûr que ça viendra
je pense que la France est dans un
mauvais cycle je suis désolé si je peux
pas paraître réac je pense que oui on
est dans une dans un toboggan et on
tombe et je pense qu'on est pas encore
tout à fait arrivé au fond donc et quand
on arrivera au fond parce que l'histoire
là quelqu'un surgira et on ne sait pas
qui et c'est très difficile mais il y a
des personnalités politiques on en
rencontre tout le temps qui serait cette
violemment qu'avant ça c'est sûr
Catherine parce que le métier politique
n'intéresse plus franchement c'est mal
payé c'est la Haute autorité sur la
transparence et le col de la suspicion
les gens on n'ont pas envie qu'on leur
de poser des questions sur leur
patrimoine à 10 ans leur facture d'il y
a 10 ans enfin des choses insupportables
bon donc tout ça fait que ben je vais
dire oui peut-être quelqu'un viendra qui
sera plus courageux que les autres parce
que je pense que c'est de plus en plus
difficile parce que ce pays aujourd'hui
est assez
et donc voilà alors cette émission
s'achève mais avant qu'elle ne s'achève
complètement il faut que que vous nous
disiez quel est le livre que vous
recommandez donc vous recommander la
lecture à nos à ceux qui nous suivent
attention c'est satisfait ou remboursé
il faut que c'est un ce soit un livre
dont il se dit c'est enthousiasmant
Catherine quel est votre choix très très
intéressant c'est le livre de Xavier
DRIANCOURT qui a été ambassadeur deux
fois en Algérie qui raconte parce que je
viens de finir le lire tous les rapports
entre la France et l'Algérie et c'est
passionnant voilà
un livre qui s'appelle Smolensk par le
François Mally et c'est aux éditions
Perrin c'est un livre que j'ai adoré qui
est formidable parce que ce malin c'est
la ville martyr en Russie vous savez les
troupes de Napoléon les nazis enfin tout
le monde c'est acharné sur cette ville
et il raconte la ville avec toutes ces
histoires vous savez ils avaient Cathy
en plus à côté les oreilles charnier de
Staline vous avez quand ils avaient tué
tous les Polonais et donc il raconte
tout ça donc smolens espèce de ville
martyrs c'est un livre absolument
formidable et très actuel donc très
actuel absolument parce que oui on est
oui ça fait pas évidemment on pense à
l'Ukraine et tout le reste alors
ça c'était en poche Waldo Emerson c'est
le philosophe c'est le père de la
philosophie américaine et c'est surtout
dit-on l'inventeur au fond de l'écologie
donc ça c'est pour vous
en anglais j'ai déjà Suzanne Zonta qui
était une grande essayiste américaine
incroyable homosexuel ami de Roland Bart
très très libre
très talentueux très intéressé à la
photographie ça c'est un petit livre
qu'elle a écrit après le 11 septembre
qui est un très très beau livre je vous
l'offre Catherine je suis sûr que ça va
vous intéresser
Oliviero Auchan balnéaire c'est un
franco libanais je crois et c'est la
guerre civile vue à travers une station
balnéaire au Liban d'un livre très
étrange mais qui qui montre le le les
rapports de de fascination et de et de
de de de haine peut avoir pour ceux qui
vous
dont vous êtes les victimes c'est une
vision de la guerre civile à travers un
petit scène fermée c'est intéressant
vous allez changer pardon je le récupère
pour Catherine bon et je donne Suzanne
et celui-là je le garde pour moi c'est
la grande histoire du Petit Nicolas ce
sont les dossiers les lettres les
dessins préparatoires du Petit Nicolas
les échanges entre San pegosinus est
absolument merveilleux voilà cette
émission est s'achève merci à Catherine
merci à France Olivier Giesbert avec qui
l'on parcourt l'un et l'autre de manière
extrêmement distrayante les 40 dernières
années ou 50 dernières années notre vie
politique merci à Noé pour sa question
merci à vous qui nous avait suivi vous
pouvez nous revoir sur le site de Public
Sénat ou bien sur votre plateforme
préférée et puis nous nous revoyons la
semaine prochaine à moins que d'ici là
nous ne nous soyons croisés dans une
librairie bonsoir
[Musique]
Public Sénat en partenariat avec le
Centre national du livre vous a présenté
au bonheur des livres
[Musique]